>> Jesse: HAVE YOU EVER BEEN IN
A BAD RELATIONSHIP?
MAYBE TWO DIFFERENT TO MAKE IT
WORK?
ONE OF YOU LIKE SLEEPING IN.
THE OTHER LIKES GETTING UP
EARLY.
MAYBE ONE OF YOU IS INTO THE BAR
SCENE BUT ANOTHER PREFERS A
NIGHT ON THE COUCH.
SOME RELATIONSHIPS JUST DON'T
WORK.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS, YOU NEED TO
END IT.
>> SOMETHING MUST HAVE HAPPENED.
>> IT'S NOT YOU.
IT'S ME.
>> YOU ARE GIVING ME THE "IT'S
NOT YOU, IT'S ME ROUTINE?"
I INVENTED QUPS IT'S NOT YOU,
IT'S ME ""IT'S THEM IF IT'S
ANYBODY IT'S ME.
>> ALL RIGHT.
GEORGE, IT'S YOU.
>> YOU'RE DAMN RIGHT IT'S ME.
>> Jesse: LOOK LIKE THE
DEMOCRATS ARE DONE TRYING TO
MAKE IT WORK WITH JOE BIDEN.
HIS APPROVAL RATING TERRIBLE.
EVEN THE MEDIA IS PROPPING HIM
UP.
HE STILL CAN'T SWING IT.
AND HE JUST CALLED HALF THE
COUNTRY FASCIST WHILE LOOKING
LIKE FROM "STAR WARS."
SO THE DEMOCRATS WHO ARE THEY
GOING TO TURN TO FOR 2024.
MAYOR PETE CAN'T GET ANYTHING
DONE.
WE HAVE ALL HAD ENOUGH OF
HILLARY.
SO IN STEPS GAVIN NEWSOM.
THE GOLDEN STATE PRETTY BOY
TRYING TO LOOK LIKE THE
FRONTRUNNER FOR THE DEMOCRATS IN
2024.
AND THEY ARE ALREADY CLEARING
THE RUNWAY.
NEWSOM STOPPED BY THE WHITE
HOUSE EARLIER.
TO GET A FEEL FOR THE PLACE.
BROUGHT IN SOME CARPET SAMPLES.
MEASURED THE DRAPES.
MAYBE HAD A FEW PAINT COLORS
WITH HIM TO SEE WHAT WORKED.
HE LOOKED RIGHT AT HOME.
AND GAVIN HASN'T BEEN SHY ABOUT
NATIONAL AMBITIONS.
ALREADY CRANKING OUT CAMPAIGN
ADS LIKE THIS ONE IN FLORIDA.
>> URGE ALL OF YOU, LIVING IN
FLORIDA TO JOIN THE FIGHT OR
JOIN US IN CALIFORNIA WHERE WE
STILL BELIEVE IN FREEDOM.
FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
FREEDOM TO CHOOSE.
FREEDOM FROM HATE AND THE
FREEDOM TO LOVE.
DON'T LET THEM TAKE YOUR
FREEDOM.
>> CALIFORNIA LOCKED DOWN.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MATTER TO
NEWSOM.
HE DOESN'T CARE NO SURPRISE HE
WENT TO WAR AGAINST FOSSIL
FUELS.
HE ALREADY BANNED THE SALE OF
GAS POWERED LAWN MOWERS IN YOUR
STATE.
EXTENSION CORD TANGLED BETWEEN
YOUR LEGS.
NOW HE IS GOING AFTER GAS
POWERED CARS.
LOOKING TO GET THEM OFF BY 2025.
SO GOOD LUCK DRIVING FROM L.A.
TO SAN FRANCISCO ON A SINGLE
CHARGE.
FREEDOM IS HAVING TO STOP AND
PLUG IN FOR THREE HOURS.
WHILE NEW SALES IS GREEN DREAM
BECOME A NIGHTMARE FOR MOST OF
THAT STATE.
CALIFORNIA'S POWER GRID CAN'T
DEMAND NOW WAIT UNTIL YOU HAVE A
GAZILLION ELECTRIC CARS CHARGING
AT THIS TIME.
STATE ON THE BRINK OF ROLLING
BLACKOUTS, DON'T WORRY, NEWSOM
HAS IT COVERED.
>> AIR CONDITIONER EARLIER IN
THE DAY WHEN MORE POWER IS
AVAILABLE.
WANTS YOU TO SWEAT IT OUT IN THE
SUMMER AND BUNDLE UP IN THE
WINTER.
AND DON'T EVEN THINK ABOUT
PUTTING UP CHRISTMAS LIGHTS.
>> CLARK!
HONEY, I THINK I KNOW WHAT'S
WRONG.
[SIREN]
>> Jesse: NEWSOM WANTS YOU TO
SUFFER FOR HIS GREEN FANTASY.
THE A.C. BUT IT LOOKS LIKE
NEWSOM IS CRANKING HIS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MANSION.
WHY IS HE WEARING A FLEECE?
ISN'T IT SUPPOSED TO BE
78 DEGREES?
SO CALIFORNIA CAN BARELY KEEP
THE LIGHTS ON.
YOU WOULD THINK THE WHITE HOUSE
WOULD THINK THAT'S A PROBLEM.
THEY DON'T.
THE WHITE HOUSE THINKS IT'S
GREAT.
>> I LOVE THE FACT THAT
CALIFORNIA IS UNABASHEDLY BOLD
ABOUT -- ABOUT ENERGY POLICY.
THE LEADER -- LEADING INDICATOR
FOR THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
CALIFORNIA'S BOLDNESS HAS, I
THINK, SHAPED OUR WILLINGNESS IN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO MOVE
FURTHER AND FASTER.
>> Jesse: TRY TELLING THAT TO
THE 35,000 PEOPLE DRENCHED IN
SWEAT SITTING IN THE DARK LAST
NIGHT.
THERE IS NOTHING BOLD ABOUT
BEING UNCIVILLIZED.
THAT'S BONE HEADED.
WHAT'S ALL THIS FOR?
THE DEMOCRATS ARE PLAYING
CHICKEN LITTLE WITH YOU AND
TELLING YOU THE SKY IS FALLING.
YOU HAVE HEARD IT EVERYWHERE
FROM AL GORE TO AOC TO GRETA.
IN RELATE THE ENVIRONMENT IS
BETTER THAN EVER.
GORE TOLD US THAT IF WE DIDN'T
UNPLUG OUR AIR DRYERS ALL THE
POLAR BEARS WERE GOING TO DIE.
>> THAT'S NOT GOOD FOR CREATURES
LIKE POLAR BEARS WHO DEPEND ON
THE ICE.
A NEW SCIENTIFIC STUDY SHOWS FOR
THE FIRST TIME THEY ARE FINDING
POLAR BEARS THAT HAVE ACTUALLY
DROWNED SWIMMING LONG DISTANCES
UP TO 60 MILES TO FIND THE ICE.
>> Jesse: GORE LIED AGAIN THE
POLAR BEAR POPULATION HAS
DOUBLED IN THE LAST 60 YEARS.
IT'S NOT JUST BEARS.
SCIENTISTS SAID THE GREAT
BARRIER REEF WAS DEAD, WAS GONE.
THIS YEAR THE CORRAL GREW FASTER
THAN EVER BEFORE.
OUR AIR HAS NEVER BEEN CLEANER.
PEOPLE USED TO THE DIE FROM
BREATHING AIR POLLUTION.
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN HERE
ANYMORE.
AND WE HAVE TAKEN SUCH GOOD CARE
OF THE OCEANS, SHARK ATTACKS ARE
UP IN THE EAST COAST GOOD THING
YOU ARE SAYING WE ARE GETTING
MORE SHARK ATTACKS IS THAT
REALLY WHAT YOU ARE SAYING?
>> THERE IS MORE LIFE IN THE
OCEAN, RIGHT?
SO THE OCEAN HAS CHANGED.
YOU AND I GREW UP WITH A REALLY
DEPLETED OCEAN.
IN THE LAST 30 YEARS THAT'S
SHIFTED A LOT SO WE NEED TO
ADAPT TO THAT.
>> Jesse: GAVIN NEWSOM AND THE
BUILDING SOLAR PANEL FARMS
DESTROYING THE ENVIRONMENT AND
BARELY POWER ANYONE'S HOMES.
AND ALL THE METALS AND MINERALS
COME FROM CHINA SO WE WILL
BECOME DEPENDENT ON CHINA JUST
LIKE THE EUROPEANS HAVE BECOME
DEPENDENT ON RUSSIA DOES THAT
SOUND LIKE A GOOD IDEA?
JUST LIKE WE NEED A BALANCED
DIET TO FUEL OUR BODIES WE NEED
A BALANCED ENERGY DIET TO FUEL
OUR COUNTRY.
EVER LOOK AT SOMEONE WHO ONLY
EATS LET TUESDAY?
THEY CAN'T GET THE JOB DONE.
SO NEWSOM IS 100 PERCENT GREEN
MANDATE IS ABOUT AS SMART AS THE
COVID MANDATES.
DON'T FOLLOW THE SCIENCE, FOLLOW
THE MONEY AND THE MONEY IS ON
GAVIN TO TAKE THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINATION